Okay. So the most ideal situation would be, if all instructions that we need to
execute just go through the pipeline in the same stage. So basically, all of,
all of them will end up executing in the same cycle.
Let's see an example of this. So we have a nice table here. And
now we're going to have some five instructions here. So let's have instructions,
so here is where we're basically just going to have our instructions. And
let's say that you know, the first instruction is an ADD instruction. R1 equals
R2 plus R3. I'm going to draw it like this so that we don't have to
actually have the opcodes and everything else clutter the screen. And
then we have R4 equals R1 minus R5.
And then we have xor R6 equals R7 X or R8.
And then we will have R5 equals R8 times R9.
And finally we will have an add of R4 equals R8 plus R9.
So remember these are instructions, not actual C-operations, it's just that I am
kind of showing them like this because it is a more compact representations of
them. And now let's see what happens in a pipeline where we do this for
a five stage pipeline. So in the first cycle, so this is cycle 1,
this will be fetched and this will be fetched and this will be fetched and
this will be fetched and this will be fetched. And then in cycle 2,
we will decode this and read registers, and decode this and read registers, and
decode this and read registers, and so on. And now if you remember your five
stage flight plan, the time comes to execute this thing. So if we just get all
five of them here and execute them. We will have a very good CPI. In reality,
what's going to happen is that we are going to eventually write the results for
all of these things. And if we had more instructions here,
it wouldn't matter. All of this would be done in basically five cycles. So
if we have five cycles for a very large number of instructions, the CPI is going
to be five cycles for pretty much an infinite number of instructions which
is going to be very close to 0. So we get a CPI for 0, which is very good.
You know, you are getting basically 0, almost 0 cycles per instruction. So
that's wonderful. So what's wrong with something like this? Well what's
wrong with it is that when we execute these instructions what has happened
is this instruction and this instruction have red registers at the same time.
Remember that the decode stage is also the read register stage.
So, what happens here is, we are here adding the R2 plus R3.
And here, when we are writing, we are really writing R1. Okay?
But when we are adding here. I mean are subtracting R5 from R1.
This R1 here is not the R1 that this instruction is writing.
It's the R1 that we read before that instruction managed to write anything.
What's wrong with this is that this first instruction is going to execute
correctly, but the second instruction because we are executing it too early,
is going to basically read the R1 from before the first instruction so
it doesn't get the result of the first instruction. So the programmer that wrote
this wanted this R1 to be this R1. It was supposed to be like this, but
it isn't. And that means that we will have to do something about this.
We cannot just let instructions execute in the same cycle.
We actually have to figure out which ones can execute and
which ones cannot execute in the same cycle.